[Music]
a 13,000 mile Dragon of Earth and stone
winds its way through the countryside of
China with a history almost as long and
serpentine as its structure the great
wall began as multiple walls of rammed
earth built by individual feudal States
during the trench ol period to protect
against nomadic Raiders north of China
and each other when Emperor Qin Shihuang
unified the states in 221 BCE the
Tibetan Plateau and Pacific Ocean became
natural barriers but the mountains in
the north remained vulnerable to Mongol
Turkish and show-nu invasions to defend
against them the emperor expanded the
small walls built by his predecessors
connecting some and fortifying others as
the structures grew from lean Hall in
the West to lay all dong in the East
they collectively became known as the
long wall to accomplish this task the
emperor enlisted soldiers and commoners
not always voluntarily of the hundreds
of thousands of builders recorded during
the Qin Dynasty many were forcibly
conscripted peasants and others were
criminals serving out sentences under
the Han Dynasty the wall grew longer
still reaching 3700 miles and spanning
from Dewan Wong to the Bohai sea forced
labour continued under the Han Emperor
hang with E and the walls reputation
grew into a notorious place of suffering
poems and legends of the time told of
laborers buried in nearby mass graves or
even within the wall itself and while no
human remains have been found inside
grave pits do indicate that many workers
died from accidents hunger and
exhaustion the wall was formidable but
not invincible
both Ganga's and his son Kubla Khan
managed to surmount the wall during the
Mongol invasion of the 13th century
after the mean dynasty gained control in
1368 they began to refortified and
further consolidate the wall using
bricks and stones from local kilns
averaging 23 feet high and 21 feet wide
the walls 5
and 500 miles were punctuated by
watchtowers when Raiders recited fire
and smoke signals traveled between
towers until reinforcements arrived
small openings along the wall led
archers fire on invaders while larger
ones were used to drop stones and more
but even this new and improved wall was
not enough in 1644 northern Manchu clans
overthrew the Ming to establish the
Ching dynasty incorporating Mongolia as
well thus for the second time China was
ruled by the very people the wall had
tried to keep out with the Empire's
borders now extending beyond the Great
Wall the fortifications lost their
purpose and without regular
reinforcements the wall fell into
disrepair rammed earth eroded while
brick and stone were plundered for
building materials but it's job wasn't
finished during World War two China used
sections for defense against Japanese
invasion and some parts are still
rumored to be used for military training
but the walls main purpose today is
cultural as one of the largest man-made
structures on earth it was granted
UNESCO World Heritage status in 1987
originally built to keep people out of
China the great wall now welcomes
millions of visitors each year
in fact the influx of tourists has
caused the wall to deteriorate leading
the Chinese government to launch
preservation initiatives it's also often
acclaimed as the only man-made structure
visible from space
unfortunately that's not at all true in
a low Earth orbit all sorts of
structures like bridges highways and
airports are visible and the Great Wall
is only barely discernible from the moon
it doesn't stand a chance but regardless
it's the earth we should be studying it
from because new sections are still
discovered every few years branching off
from the main body and expanding this
remarkable monument to human achievement
[Music]